oh
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferris show
my guest today is a fan favorite one of
my favorites jack cornfield so jack is
one of the few people i have on speed
dial if i hit particularly acute
existential distress
or anxiety and this is roughly a two
year anniversary since we recorded an
episode which i suggest everyone listen
to
right at the early stages of covet this
was in march of 2020 so who is jack jack
cornfield trained as a buddhist monk in
the monasteries of thailand india and
burma he has taught meditation
internationally since 1974 and is one of
the key teachers to introduce buddhist
mindfulness practice to the west jack
co-founded the insight meditation
society in barrie massachusetts with
fellow meditation teachers sharon
salzberg and joseph goldstein goldstein
goldstein
it's the german it's the spending time
in germany that always messes me up
there and the spirit rock center in
woodacre california which is stunning i
have spent some time there we talked
about that in our first conversation
over the years jack has taught worldwide
led international buddhist teacher
meetings and worked with many of the
great teachers of our time he holds a
phd in clinical psychology
and i just want to mention an aside here
one of the things that i love about you
jack and respect about you is that you
spend time both in the deeply
philosophical
i shouldn't say both there are many sort
of stems to this the
deeply contemplative but also in the
deeply clinical and you've worked with
many many different patient groups so i
think that provides you with a very
interesting and eclectic
broad spectrum toolkit so i just want to
say that for people who may not be
familiar
with you
and jumping back in you are also a
grandfather husband and activist some of
your current projects include mmtcp a
worldwide mindfulness teacher training
cloud sangha
if i'm pronouncing that correctly this
is another word that i have trouble with
yeah you've done it nailed it
s-a-n-g-h-a
a site offering access to expert
mindfulness teachers online and a
positive impact wisdom ventures fund his
books have been translated into 22
languages and have sold more than 1.5
million copies i have read many of them
they include a wise heart subtitle a
guide to the universal teachings of
buddhist psychology a path with heart
after the ectasy the laundry one of my
favorite titles
teachings of the buddha the art of
forgiveness loving kindness and peace
bringing home the dharma subtitle
awakening right where you are and his
most recent book is no time like the
present subtitle finding freedom love
and joy right where you are you can find
him online
jackcornfield.com that's
k-o-r-n-f-i-e-l-d
dot com on twitter jack cornfield
instagram jack underscore cornfield jack
it's so nice to see you again thank you
for making the time
it's a pleasure tim happy to see you and
very glad to know that you're
and that you brought rain with you
concerns you forgot to be the rain maker
after all and we really need it out west
so way to go
thank you thank you i do what i can to
where i can so
i just need to figure out
exactly how i managed to precipitate
this this rain and replicate that but
that's that's a project for after the
podcast
jack there's so many different places we
could start i thought i would begin with
explaining one of our most recent
conversations and that was prompted by
feeling some amount of existential
distress that has been on slow burn for
a while now and we don't have to start
here in terms of our conversation but i
want to mention it to folks just to
underscore the fact that
i do have you on the speed dial per se
because of your deep expertise and
awareness related to certain things and
in this case it was
angst and distress related to
climate change extreme weather events
and noticing a growing apathy
feeling of learned helplessness perhaps
in my audience which
scares me more than most things i mean
there's a lot of strife there's a lot of
anger and i think these things may be
intertwined
and
we'll probably cover all of these in our
conversation
now just to set the set the stage for
this uplifting conversation before we
started recording i asked what we might
chat about and you said well death war
and anger so we
we will cover all the cheerful topics
all the cheerful topics enjoy no and joy
and well-being but you know we have to
make the descent and then come back i'll
reborn into a new brighter world exactly
so let's start with anger because you
know in between my
rainmaking activities in the dry alpine
west
i also make time for stupid arguments
over breakfast one of which i had this
morning i think that was also
precipitated by yours truly so not all
great things
and
you mentioned you have a number of
stories before we start recording
related to anger so let's let's start
there and i'll i'll let you lead
wherever you think it makes sense
i will but let me ask you a question
first
why do you ask about anger what is your
intention or what makes you ask
well i ask about anger because
i notice
as i reflect on
not just my own behavior but behavior
that is common in my family
a tendency towards perhaps an emotional
home base of anger it's a very familiar
feeling and i recognize how it can be
corrosive
and i've spoken to people who have
wanted to discuss
their respective perspectives on say
clean anger
i have tried to contend with it
in different ways some have suggested
fully expressing it hitting a pillow
working on a punching bag
that tends to amplify and
perpetuate anger in me so it does not
have the desired effect of dissipating
anger at all it just
turns it from a seven to a ten
and
it's something i wanna work on because i
also recognize that even when i convey
neutral content from the perspective of
the words that i choose sometimes my
tone has an undercurrent of anger
and that causes strife that causes
arguments that causes
various types of tension and
a lot of it most of it is not helpful so
that is that is part of why i ask and
if if i may just add one more thing from
a
macro societal perspective
i have never seen more polarization and
anger
than i see today just observing this
audience of let's call it 10 to 20
million people a month
as i look at all of it from a 30 000
foot view i have never seen
so much
anger and hostility ever
in all my time on this planet so that's
also frightening
so that really helps me a lot because
your openness about it is actually what
we need if we bury it or stuff it
it just festers and as you say you can
try to be nice and it seeps out in the
tone of your voice and people feel that
we we resonate with one another it's not
a complicated thing you could call it
mystical but if you put a violin on the
table and somebody else plays a violin
nearby the strings of both of them will
resonate and so
yes there you're looking so nice and
then that little stuff seeps out so i've
i've really had to wrestle with anger a
lot
and the greeks call it a noble emotion
the philosophers because there's
something of value in it so the first
thing i want to say is that anger
in itself isn't bad it's difficult to
work with but it's not a bad thing
it's something for us to understand
because it's part of human incarnation
and often the anger
comes out of hurt
or it comes out of fear
ways that we feel vulnerable it's a way
of protecting ourselves
james baldwin said
i believe the reason
that people cling to their hate and
anger so stubbornly
is because
they're afraid that once hate is gone
they'll be forced to face their own pain
and so we also project it on others you
know the ones that that cause our pain
and so forth instead we get angry
as if they were the ones making it
happen and we have the enemy du jour it
doesn't matter right now it's russia and
everybody's cheering we have a the
pentagon is like
you know
i don't know what to say they're they're
celebrating we have a great enemy again
and a bigger budget and so forth you
know but it can be the immigrants or the
mexicans or the blacks or the gays or
the you know whoever it is the enemy the
jeweler
because we can't bear our insecurity
and we can't bear the fact that we're
vulnerable in certain ways
and that what's out there is also part
of us so alexander solzhenitsyn the
great russian author when he was in the
gulags writing these brilliant things
and sent out the
siberia he said if only it were simple
if only
we could just round up the evil people
and get rid of them
but the problem is the line dividing
good and evil
cuts through
the heart of every human being
and who among us is willing to get
to to get rid of a piece of our own
heart
so this is where we are as human beings
so here i am
i'm in the monastery i did some years
training as a buddhist monk
and in my family there were four boys
and we each had different roles my
brother got angry a lot i think that was
the healthiest in some way because my
father was
angry paranoid wife batterer
somewhat mentally ill and also a
brilliant scientist who helped develop
some of the first artificial hearts and
lungs and did space medicine and stuff
but he was he was a terrifying figure in
many ways
so i was the peacemaker in the family
trying to calm it down
i've now made that a profession you know
how that goes
and i go in the monastery and i'm
sitting minding my own business
meditating walking slowly in the forest
in the remote part of thailand on the
border of laos that's
an ascetic forest monastery i wanted
something tough you know we're young man
is there anything dangerous to do around
here let me try it
and i start to sit
and at some point not
not that long in my time there the first
months i start to get more and more
irritated at the way the monks around me
are behaving and the problems and you
know this one and that one
and then i just notice that i'm getting
angrier
and all of a sudden i realize
that i have a lot of anger
it just starts boiling up because
there's no distraction and i can't put
it on somebody else really
and
and so i go to talk to my teacher about
it i said you know all this anger is
bubbling up and basically it shocked me
because i thought i was a peaceful
person and mostly i just didn't want to
be like my father and hurt people
so i'm not going to be like him but
turns out
he's in there and it's all in there and
i and i tell i don't show my teacher
and he looks at me and he says good
he said great this this is what you need
to look at he said i want you to go back
to your little hut and a tin roof you
know close the one window and door put
on all your robes this is the hot season
and if you're gonna be angry do it right
he didn't say go beat something he just
said sit in the middle of it take the
seat
and feel the fire of it and learn first
of all learn to tolerate it
because part of what happens with anger
is when we can't tolerate the emotions
and so forth then we lash out or it
leaks in our words
he said so go and sit and bring your
mindfulness to it and learn
to tolerate it because a lot of the
power of meditation as the
neuroscientists say
is to increase the window of tolerance
so you don't get reactive to things but
you have the ability to feel things
fully and then decide how to express it
so i sit there
and after a while it's like okay anger
comes and the great image in in the
buddhist teaching is that the buddha
seated under the tree of enlightenment
that big world story or myth and while
he's sitting there he gets attacked by
the armies of mara you have no right to
sit here again mara comes as doubt
mara brings temptations you know and
then it was all the beautiful maidens
and a golden chariot you could have all
these things that buddha says no been
there done that you know i want
something freer than that
and then mara attacks him with spears
and flaming arrows and things
and the buddha's response
is to say i see you mark
mark comes back other times in buddha's
life and the main thing that the buddha
does he doesn't fight mara doesn't con
says i see who you are i see you
and in that you can feel that there's a
freedom in the heart a spaciousness to
be present for it
so i get better with this chip right i'm
okay now i'm not not quite so angry i
know i have it
i leave the monastery after some years i
go back
to
new england where i've been last
hook up with an old girlfriend who was
great she was
doing graduate teaching at harvard
and very quickly we get into conflict
and i realized okay it's one thing to
deal with anger in myself
but being a monk
i had no training in how to deal with
relationship
you know and going back was hard
people talk about leaving the monastery
going back to their family they they
forget that both jesus and buddha had a
hard time when they went home to their
families
this is like the real place
so i'm there with this woman and all my
neurosis comes up my neediness my
whatever you know fears all the things
about around intimacy that i didn't have
to deal with as a monk
so i start
to
do that and and i realize that anger is
building up again she was great actually
she said okay
you dealt with it in yourself now let's
let's do this together so she says come
with me she had an old bulbous station
wagon and in the back
she had 10 cases big cases of bottles
and she said come with me she drove me
to an old
place where they were demolishing a
brick building she said all right get
out i want you to
throw those suckers at the wall you know
and say whatever you have so you just
about me but i would just let it out not
so much as pounding the bag but just
making it all conscious it wasn't like i
have to do that every day
and then i went into a reiki in therapy
and this guy said you have the monks
defense you can be aware of anything but
you're afraid to actually express it so
he said jack may i interrupt for a
second what type of therapist was that
he worked with wilhelm reich who was a
a contemporary right after freud who
work with the energy and sexuality body
and he asked me
what time of day is hardest for you
and i said morning i'm not a morning
person he said great i'll see you at 6
a.m
when your defenses are down
so i go in and he has me do these
breathing exercises to charge up my body
play some evocative music and starts
working on my body saying you've got to
let this stuff out whatever it is okay
he worked on my body so hard one day he
cracked two ribs actually
i wept
i i cried i got angry i did all these
things so this was part of my learning
it
and now i'm a lot less afraid of it and
and therefore i also can use it so when
i had my house being rebuilt we were
supposed to go to europe and the
contractor who was a good guy kept
saying we're you know we're a little
behind i said we you got to finish
before we travel for a long time
he's putting it off and i kept asking
nice guy that i am and he says
finally i said
you know we've only got a month to go
and you little teams and i yelled at him
i said
man if you don't finish this i'm going
to sue your ass in court i'm going to
get that you know i'm just tired of this
[ __ ] and i'm really angry and he looks
at me and says oh you really want it
done don't you
and i said yeah next day he said like a
triple crew and i realized that i simply
needed to speak contractors i was kind
of speaking like buddhist monk but that
was not his language
so it became easier in some way
to work with it and to realize that you
know i have my own inner taliban i have
my own inner iron curtain that it's not
just out there and by taking this energy
and saying yes
this is something that i can work with
it just becomes much easier for me and
it runs through me quicker it's not that
it doesn't i mean i watch stick not han
or the dalai lama get angry or upset so
it's not like it won't it's part of us
and then i guess the last thing to say
because it also allows for a kind of
graciousness
about it
when i see myself getting angry
if you really look
what i really look underneath anger is
hurt or fear
or some kind of humiliation or something
like that where you feel like you've
been disrespected
and if i can drop from the anger to say
what what's under this and then express
it and say i really feel hurt when you
say that or that makes me afraid
that very conflict
with another person or a group of people
it changes from being i'm right and
you're wrong to
this hurts or i'm afraid about this and
we can have a genuine conversation
that's entirely different
so i'll pause here because that's a lot
of story
that is and i want to i want to dive
right back in to the stories
and your teacher's name
one of your teachers
so i recall from
looking at my notes from an earlier
conversation that we've had on this
podcast you tell the story
of being out with this teacher
collecting alms
food yeah one day when you saw a big
rock in the middle of a rice paddy tell
me if i get any of these details wrong
and ajan chah asked is that boulder
heavy
and a number of the young monks said yes
it is master and then he replied with
not if you don't pick it up
and being able to witness what's present
without being lost in it now let's
contrast that for a second because i
feel like you said this internal
iron curtain sometimes or this internal
conflict between
not picking up the boulder right so not
voluntarily
over exerting
and
speaking contractories so my question
for you is
if you have the impulse to speak
contractors we're just like for [ __ ]
sake
enough is enough like so-and-so isn't
doing the job they're supposed to do
how do you
surgically use contractors
in your own life and know when to
turn off mr nice guy
and speak more directly
because that i imagine can also become a
hammer looking for nails right and i
think that's something that i do where
where someone might excuse constantly
speaking to everyone in contractors with
well i'm just keeping it real or i'm
just being honest or whatever the
phrases that they use to
deflect the fact that they're just being
an [ __ ] a lot of the time
how do you think about that
so i would in a certain way i'd offer
you a challenge because you like
challenges you're one of those guys who
said anything dangerous to do around
here but it's both outward and inward
and the challenge would be this
that when you speak from that place
which i do and it has its time
often it makes things worse i think
benjamin franklin said what begins in
anger ends in suffering generally
speaking
so the challenge is can you speak your
truth
that's underneath the anger
can you say
i'm worried this isn't that isn't going
to happen or that this is all going to
fall apart or i feel so hurt you know
when you say those kind of things so
when you do those things can you
actually drop when you when you be now
you're aware of your anger
and allow a certain
deeper level of understanding and then
express it
it doesn't mean that there might not be
occasions when you need to stand up but
when you talk about
saying saying the truth tim
the problem is that the pesky little
word truth you know
because there's a truth of how tim sees
it and how it should be but there's
another truth that you feel worried or
hurt or anxious or right
and so that's also true
and that's a different truth that's even
more challenging sometimes to express
but it connects you
you know and and when people are arguing
i think about in couples
you know you can say the the simplest
thing like what did you mean
but with different tones of voice like
what did you mean you know and it's like
an attack right or you can say what did
you mean i really want to understand you
it's the very same words but the feeling
that's communicated is either blame or
it's i'm actually curious what's going
on in you what did you mean
and so there's no simple answer but it's
like riding a bike yeah you fall off
each side and you practice it
so let me once again turn this
conversation into just a self-serving
therapy session because i i think that
if it helps me it'll probably help at
least until later
it'll help at least a few other people
out there and i also don't want to
misrepresent myself i'm not just raging
throwing rocks through windows non-stop
24 7. i think maybe you can correct me
from wrong but i think it was the buddha
who said if you walk outside
and one day you meet one [ __ ] that
person's an [ __ ] but if you walk
outside and everyone's an [ __ ] you're
the [ __ ] i might be misattributing
that it could have been abraham lincoln
or oscar wilde but
i do i do think about that so i'm not
i'm not uh
raging i'm not a rachel hall like i
wouldn't say but
the biggest challenge i think that i
have is not the words i use but the
slight edge or tone
that
i think whether by genetics or
environment i have adopted because there
was a lot of this
in my household
i'm unclear on how to
systematically work on catching that
tone and i have to imagine it begins
with awareness now retrospectively i'm
aware
for instance this morning i what i what
the issue wasn't what i said it was
probably the edge with which i said it
yeah
do you have any suggestions for how to
how to work on that
it's a deep and a beautiful question for
us as human beings because it it can be
anger or it can be other patterns you
know
addictive patterns or or other things
that we fall into and you said something
you know straight up right away the
first step is just to be aware of it
because if you're not aware of it it's
you're on automatic pilot
the next step
is you said i'm aware of it
retrospectively you want to move the
time a little closer to when it happens
and there are two things you can do one
is pause
start to tune yourself you can even take
a little notebook i think it's a great
thing anyway get get a little notebook
and put the word anger on the first page
and then just periodically let yourself
write about it so you let what
images of your family anger about the
world the climate river you just let it
so you start to see okay this is the
repository of angry this is what i'm
learning about it this is when it comes
so you're making it more conscious
then as you catch up to it more in the
current moment when it arises
the next step is to pause
and with your notebook if you if you
kind of write down
little examples you don't have to fill
it with pages but all right this morning
tone of voice i got
then you can begin to imagine or feel a
different scenario don't even do it out
loud yet but imagine
what upset you in the morning
even with that little tone you say you
know how else could i handle this what
else
and the thing is that the imagination
has an enormous capacity to change our
our neural structure how we envision
as you know
olympic athletes they envision and they
go into a game and they do better you
know this very well you actually get to
envision yourself all right now i am the
buddha i have a certain fierce
compassion so you haven't put it all
aside
but basically i'm a gracious and
caring human being what would that how
would that come out in this situation
and you start to realize that you have
this capacity if you really begin to
look at it to transform your patterns
which is what
that's why it's called practice rather
than perfect you know whether it's
meditation practice or something else
there's a word currency in spanish
and it refers to the place in
bullfighting
where the bull stops
in the middle of the ring at some point
but the fighter there the bull and the
matador are facing off right
and the matador finds his currencia
it's the place
in the middle of all that energy
which is unmoving
which is just
here i am on the earth there's the bull
there's all of this stuff
if you find that
in yourself
when you practice when you learn to find
that
in a pause then it gives you all kinds
of other opportunities and i remember
this woman coming to see me who is in
the middle of a terrible divorce so you
know we're talking real things here
her ex-husband who is also you know a
wealthy lawyer hired a
killer lawyer he was going to keep the
kids and keep all the money he was angry
at her even though he's the one that had
the affairs but
anyway so i said first of all get
yourself a kick-ass lawyer to defend
yourself
um read that from the buddha i don't
know anyway wherever
but we work for a while and she came in
one day because he was trying to turn
their children against her
which is like
one of the greatest pains a parent can
have
but
you know also not so uncommon
and she said i sat with it
i let myself feel all the pain
and the tremendous amount of grief and
that's part of our work was just the
grief of it
and then she came in one day and she
said i will not bequeath
a legacy of bitterness to my children
i will not say a bad thing about their
father i simply will not do it and that
was the currency that was it doesn't
matter what the bull does i know what my
values are and i know who i am
and that
you have that in yourself there's
that power is in you
so jack i want to
make sure that we talk about
sounds strange to segway in this fashion
but talk about death and from the notes
that we exchanged before we started
recording what happens
as you die or when you die but before we
get to that so give give people
something to look forward to
i wanted to chat with you a bit about
something you and i haven't spent that
much time talking about offline and i
feel like these
this may connect closely to my
anger response
or just general kind of aggressive
response to the world and that is hyper
vigilance so you you know about my
childhood trauma and my traumatic
background per se for people who want
more on that just search my name and
trauma and it'll pop right up so we
won't get into it right now but
there's a there's a degree of hyper
vigilance and always seeking safety and
maximizing or optimizing for safety
that i
think may be the foundation under which
a lot of this
anger arises and i'm wondering how you
have worked with people
whether they have complex ptsd or
undiagnosed
traumatic response in the form of hyper
vigilance how do you work on that with
people
well first of all i'm just listening to
you
and feeling the suffering of it
not just for you but for the child that
you were
and for the child of
so many people who are listening the
childhood not everybody's but i became
somewhat that way not that perhaps as
much as you because i didn't know when
the car pulled in the driveway whereas
was i going to get a raging you know
violent maniac father or just a kind of
ordinary father
so i had to be vigilant like you
underneath that
there's fear but there's also a lot of
grief
the loss of what could have been a
healthier family
the grief that that child wasn't
protected
and so forth
so for me part of what helps with the
vigilance
is bringing a kind of compassion
to that frightened part of ourselves
because it's not just you as an adult
but as you point out it's really that
hyper vigilance was learned
long ago to protect you
and so i will do
a practice of
having people
visualize themselves when they had to
learn that when they weren't safe
do some compassion practice put their
arm around that child hold
that part of themself really
in some way
and also begin to say
to all that fear
kind of almost like a mantra
representation
thank you for trying to protect me
because the wires in the fight flight or
freeze immediately the brainstorm i'm
you know the tigers coming or whatever
thank you for trying to protect me you
feel your vulnerability
i'm okay just now
i'm all right thank you you can relax
and it becomes actually a practice where
you let yourself
feel the hyper vigilance and you say
thank you for trying to protect me so
you're not suppressing it you actually
honor it because it kept you safe
and you say and right now i'm okay and
then you let yourself feel it in your
body
i actually am okay in this moment i'm
saying thank you i'll be all right
and again it becomes kind of a training
that you do
where you are
acknowledging
what's true the suffering of it
the activation
and the grief that's underneath it the
tears that are under it
and now we're kind of also in the
territory of trauma which you and i have
talked about before
and is so important in this time
i might have i don't know in that last
conversation we had in the podcast
i i probably referred to some of the
retreats that we did
michael mead luis rodriguez other
com padres of mine compatriots with
returning vets from the middle east
who have tremendous amount of trauma
and part of what
was needed was to make a safe enough
space
that they could
bring out in a conscious way that which
was
kept inside
out of fear to protect themselves and
others so we got combat vets together
and part of it was to write
or talk or tell your story
and these are stories that they couldn't
tell anybody else you can't
go home and tell people the graphic
details of what happened in the battle
zone it would
it would shatter them
i know it also
like working with
physicians and nurses from the
neonatal
units in the hospital and my beloved
trudy who has done that work
talks about how the nurses come home and
they can't tell the people around them
that this week i held
three babies in my arms as they died
and describing can't do it so the vets
say i can't i can't and this was the
powerful thing
i can't tell you what i saw
and i can't tell you what i had to do
and that's the worst because it's a kind
of weight on the soul
of a vet
so first we got them together and as
combat vets
they fell found a safe space to tell
their stories that they couldn't tell to
anybody else
and we also invited them to write a
story or write a poem or begin to
articulate it
and it's held in the body so there was
movement that we did and you know
martial art kind of things
there was some
some group songs the songs of warriors
returning from africa or tibet or you
know the mayan that we could chant
together in the stories of what it meant
for a warrior to put down their armor
and come home
and become again
part of those who till the fields and
care for their families and there are
all these ancient myths about it
and people began to let all that out
that they were carrying
and in the end
we invited their family to come in
and each man stood up and told at least
some part of the story that they'd never
told before
and as each person spoke when it was
done
there was a
a group
chant
of honoring them and saying we now
welcome you back
a warrior who've done done your deeds as
a warrior
you can let that go now and we welcome
you back as a human being in a new way
in our mid
and
i mean otherwise people get out of the
military and the bus stops at the you
know corner or whatever and they're left
out and
nobody knows
nobody attends them
so we tell the story partly because it's
important in terms of trauma
that it's held in our body we need to be
able to tell the story we need others
also around us
to witness us
and to see
that this isn't who we who you really
are this was a
role you took on
but it's not who you really are
and that mirroring also has a tremendous
kind of benefit or blessing when you're
seen
in a different way because then you can
start to see yourself in a different way
i sort of digressed from your question
but no it's it's i don't think it's a
digression i think i think these are
parallel tracks and they're probably
converging tracks at certain points i
realize those two don't go together for
those people out there who are sticklers
about
parallel but
a question that comes to mind for me
also which is very front and center as i
think about
mental health new therapeutics new
models for trying to address mental
health
the united states just as a country is
woefully under prepared
for
the sheer volume
of
patient cases that that need to be dealt
with if you compare them to
almost any other first world country
whether it's a scandinavian country or
even much larger countries
from a from the perspective of having
trained psychologists and psychiatrists
that the u.s really has
woefully inadequate ratios
which which leads me to wonder
how you think about group therapy
dynamics because it seems like
one way to increase the treatable
population while decreasing the per
person costs
and this applies as you just indicated
not just in some of the spheres that i
know well and you know extremely well
but let's just say in the psychedelic
therapeutics
arena where you could look at group
therapies and integration with some of
these different compounds whether it's
mdma or
others say psilocybin for treatment
resistant or major depressive disorder
but it applies also in unenhanced
environments like the veteran example
that you just provided
do you have any thoughts on
paths forward or paths worth exploring
with respect to group therapeutic models
yeah because it seems like it's not just
a way to
i want to emphasize in my mind it's not
just a way to decrease cost it's also a
way to in many many instances improve
outcomes
rather than having one-on-one isolated
treatments
yes
so first i want to note something else
just as we
we have a mental health crisis here and
vivek murthy who's the current surgeon
general and a great guy that i know
said
in what he's seen more than half of what
comes through the doors of our hospitals
and clinics presenting as physical
problems really has its root
in emotions and mental
that it's the level of stress and that
that's really part of the crisis and
that gets
you know we were allowed to have a
medical problem but it's actually not
tended there was a a section of the wall
street journal a dozen years ago or so
it was the front page of it actually
and it talked about the over medication
of children
from the wall street journal
saying that 45 million of our children
are on
antidepressants or adhd medication
or anti-hypertensive
you know or
antipsychotic or various diff
medications like that
huge number
and then we have to pause and say our
children why
even before we get to your question of
how do we how do we heal
there's something about the way
our culture
the drivenness of our culture you know
and the
the outer focus of it
in which we're actually not listening to
our children
and you see it in all kinds of ways
i don't even have to go any further you
know but even the kind of
terrible gun violence that we see and so
forth in some way comes out of a
tremendous amount of pain in childhood
i'm not trying to make any excuse for
that but
so here we are we're in a culture now
let's just look at it clearly we're a
culture that doesn't know how to do this
and i think it has to happen on a lot of
levels you're correct
that this isn't an individual problem
and people will come to see me and say i
have a tremendous amount of anxiety
right now
and i'm anxious about this this this in
my life and i look at them i see that
you may be anxious about that but you're
living in a culture that's
suffused with anxiety right now it's not
just the earth you're actually swimming
in the psyche or the field of
consciousness around you and it's in the
news and it's what people talk about and
you can't not feel it so it's not just
personal
nor is it personal to those children and
in some ways stepping back and seeing
that already starts to give you a little
relief okay it's not my fault
i'm you know i'm not doing something
wrong because we can so easily judge
one another or judge
you know our mental state
so then going to your very
important question
there are no math new modalities of
healing and certainly some of the
psychedelic
work with psilocybin
ketamine
mdma tremendously helpful and promising
but the other part which you talk about
and it's really the epidemic of
loneliness it's what the vets were
feeling when they were in their home
alone and they couldn't talk to anybody
about all that was inside them
is that we need each other
and healing is not an individual matter
for almost everybody this human being
especially the healing of the heart and
the psyche
we need to hear each other
to comfort each other to allow the
measure of grief
and with it then to allow something more
beautiful to arise because if you could
see the vets after that retreat there
was there was a tremendous amount of
love that grew that they could express
because they felt free in themselves in
some way and so
it's not just that you want to get back
to okay i can function again
but that you want to renew your heart
and you want to renew your soul and your
spirit and that's possible and usually
it needs to be done together it can only
be done
in yourself
so jack let me ask you a question about
the
anxiety suffused
society in which we find ourselves and
this is a question i'm i i'm very
interested in personally
so
to what extent
do you think about
creating
the
ideal environment for yourself and your
loved ones
versus
adjusting to an anxiety suffused society
that is unlikely
to be wholly changed by your efforts and
it makes me think of a very often
quoted quote of krishnamurti's which is
it is no measure of health to be well
adjusted to a profoundly sick society
but one could argue that that is
absolving yourself of any responsibility
so how do you think about
choosing between those two
or a ratio between those two
or contending with that tension if
they're if you see any tension between
those two i love your question because
it's a little like a zen koan you know
the world is on fire it's in flames do i
stay around and
try to put the fire out or the titanic's
going down do i help people into the in
the lifeboats you know or do i flee do i
go in the mountains or do i get a little
lifeboat and so forth
do i stay or do i go
and the answer to those kind of koans is
yes
you gave the little mathematical answer
how do you titrate it
in some fashion because i think it's
both you know the metaphor that everyone
uses these days is you know put on your
oxygen mask first before you put it on
your children
there's a way in which we have a
responsibility to ourselves
to try to stay healthy and well
and i know
you know if i go into a refugee camp it
doesn't help if i go in and i'm
depressed and anxious
they're already feeling that they don't
need me to breathe they actually need
somebody who says yeah this is suffering
and there are ways to manage it there
are ways even though it's difficult
there are ways and there are
possibilities
for us
the great anthropologist and philosopher
wade davis said
despair
is a failure of the imagination
that's a good one it's a brilliant line
because it speaks to the heart despair
is a failure of the imagination
human beings have been in tough times
since caves and saber-toothed tigers
since you know
battles between different clans
and then we don't have to talk about
the huns and the visigoths or the roman
army or the you know the armies of the
aztecs or wherever around the world
we human beings have dealt with
epidemics
blood
tornadoes
continuing war is not a new story right
and we're survivors
and we survive
in two ways first of all we survive by
protecting what we care about which is
ourselves and those close to us so i do
that i want to protect my grandson have
them live in a place where it's safe if
if that's possible or safe enough
or myself
but i also don't want to turn away
for two reasons
my daughter said well if climate change
and everything gets battery you know
would you move to new zealand or would
you you know would you get and i said
you know i
i choose to be on the deck of the
titanic and i'll help people in the
lifeboats that's just
that's what i've
taken as a vow as a bodhisattva that you
turn towards suffering and you offer
what you can
but part of that offering
is to see that the world that i want for
my grandson needs my attending
and it doesn't mean i can change it
because this is the way the world in
some ways but it can be better or it can
be worse and we know that we can stand
up for things that really
matter and so your question which is a
really it's a question of the heart it's
also different for different people
there's some people who are profoundly
contemplative and i think the extreme
are those tibetan yogi's in the cave who
are broadcasting compassion to everybody
in the world
if we're all connected as they say as we
find
then that's their contribution
but then there i was out on the streets
in march for your lives in dc for this
and that was also important
and i love the fact it was not this one
but with the prior march for your lives
i forget who it was but there was a
fantastic you know
black gospel singer who stood up
and she's saying
in a sort of gospel style bob dylan's
the times they are a change in
you know 40 years after it came out
gather around people that times are
changing don't block up the wall and i
listened and it was it was the very same
medicine that we needed
and i felt so glad to be out there with
people and i felt so glad that
we were doing lobbying petitions and
sending money and trying to support the
organizations and do what we could
and i've also worked with kids coming
out of street gangs in the cities
and they're
they're veterans too when we've had
retreats with
army veterans
military veterans coming back combat
veterans
and some of these young kids
they look at each other
in their eyes and they nod and they know
that they've all been together in battle
because some of these kids have seen as
much shooting as some of these events
have
and so
we actually need to tend to that
and it becomes part of our
i don't know our
any part of our life purpose
in some way yes to take care of yourself
but yourself isn't separate
to take care of yourself is everything
so jack let me
ask you
and i'm going to say a bit but the basic
question is what makes
an effective
bodhisattva versus an ineffective
bodhisattva so the seven habits for the
effective buddhist
or something like that i love it
well it's like silicon valley you know
if you can measure it then you can
change it right now yeah right
and i don't want to over secularize and
pull all the magic out of it but
let me let me just
riff for a second yeah you'll see where
this is coming from as i mentioned
earlier and i'm going to
circle back to this i've i've never
before noticed so much apathy and
disengagement and
anxiety and depression in my audience of
let's call it 10 to 20 million who i
think are fairly representative across a
very broad spectrum of not just american
but global society but let's just stick
with u.s society at the moment it's
every race every creed every political
orientation
and
i think one contributing factor this is
a theory
is that never before have people
been exposed to
constant
global
bad news
of every type
and
so the the question of how to be an
effective bodhisattva stems from
something that i've been
journaling on myself in the last few
weeks and it came about from reading a
revised edition of a book called the 80
20 principle
and it talked it talks about in one
section happiness islands and
identifying your closest say ten
relationships that
bring you peak positive emotional states
and i began to after i made this list
ask myself whenever i got an email
asking for a coffee date or a phone call
or fill in the plank
would i rather spend time with this
person
or
if i look at my list of top 10
relationships and ask myself the
question am i spending as much time with
these 10 people as i would like if the
answer is no would i be better served
and would our relationships be better
served by me focusing on these 10
relationships
and so i
i found myself feeling this tension
between trying to serve
in my capacity as a writer and a host of
a podcast
some amorphous larger group
or
would we
on some level be all better served if
each of us just said hey make a list of
your top 10 most important relationships
and go serve those 10.
and i'm sure it's not as binary it
doesn't need to be one or the other but
that's why i ask this question because
there are a lot of well-intentioned
people who want to do good but they're
so scattered and their goals are so
unclear that they never really
produce
much
and that's a very rambling
long compound question but you see where
i'm going i think it's a great question
because it's carried in the hearts of a
lot of the people listening
part of the reason i i think as you
point out that people
aren't responding maybe as effectively
as they might
is because they are overwhelmed and
there is a kind of despair and it feels
like
a helplessness that sweeps over a lot of
people the problems are too big it's not
possible
one of my
favorite
friends colleagues mentors is a woman
named joanna macy who's been working on
nuclear disarmament climate
change issues world peace all kinds of
things for decades now she's in her 90s
and years ago she started
i think it was together with john seed
and other environmentalists
as a series of practices called the
council for all beings
then it was part of what she calls
despair and empowerment work
and that phrase really carries a lot
so people would come and they meditate
and they talk about
the issues of climate change and so
forth and then they would be asked to be
silent for a day or two while they were
there in some camp out in nature
and to go out and find whether in the
forest and the stream around or in their
imagination it could be the
polar bears in the arctic or whatever
some profound connection
that they have with the natural world of
something that they really care about
and then because she's playful about it
they had all kinds of stuff there she
said okay come back and dress up as your
as your thing so people came
you know there was some decades ago but
in any case they came back and they made
a circle
and in that circle
they were asked to speak for that
part of life that they felt so deeply
connected to it someone would sit up and
say i speak for the salmon
i'm a salmon potion i speak for the
salmon here is what i need and yes
here's my grief
and here is what i am empowered to do
now
someone else said i speak for the
redwoods or i speak for the monarch
butterflies or i speak for the whatever
it happened to be
and it required and invited people
to be willing to face the very thing you
talk about the apathy
the despair and say yes i'll give voice
to that
and then to
bind themselves to something they care
about like those 10 people in the circle
that you said that you most care about
maybe you could expand the circle a
little bit further and say and are there
a few other beings in this world might
be the ukrainians or it might be the
polar bears you know
might be the monarch butterflies or it
might be
boss children in foster care
it's not your task to fix the world that
would be hubris okay i'm
jack cornfield and i'm the bodhisattva
and i'll fix it all nobody's ever done
that right
but it is your task to feel
your care
and to extend it to make to put your
oxygen mask on to make something that's
safe and sacred as best you can around
you
and then extend that
with your particular gift your gift is
partly through your podcast and your
writing
others it might be
you know
planning a community garden
or their own amazing garden and giving
some of the fruit away or or
starting a conscious business
and doing it with the intention to make
business that brings well-being to
people who work for it and so forth
there are a million ways to do it nobody
can tell you how
you have to listen and nobody else the
other thing is that nobody else can do
it for you i mean you are doing it
in a way so yeah you spend plenty of
time with those 10 people hallelujah i
encourage it
and i don't believe you're going to stop
your podcast and i don't want you to
no i'm not going to stop my podcast
you've got both you i actually
in a way you're asking something that
you've in part you've already answered
so there's a story of a woman
she was a teacher in a school maybe it
was middle school or something like that
in the tenderloin in san francisco in
the kind of the
most difficult poorest part of the city
more people without homes and so forth
and um when she got home she had an
apartment near there
if she had extra bandwidth that she
wasn't too tired she would make
sandwiches
and go down and give them to the
homeless people
in the neighborhood
and little by little people found out
about it and she became a kind of minor
celebrity
for giving out the sandwiches
and uh once that was found out somebody
wrote something about stuff she started
to receive envelopes of money for your
good work for the homeless
and she answered them all
with a one-line note in fact she said
make your own damn sandwiches
[Laughter]
and that's it it's not that we have to
carry it for someone else
but that each person actually has to
decide
what their gift is
and no matter how much despair you have
i want to ask you on behalf of my
grandchildren
to extend your hand and bend something
to connect with somebody
to do something not just on behalf of
them because actually i know that it's
good for us in our human incarnation for
our soul somehow
that's part of the answer to it
it's not just despair but it's
empowerment and realizing that
the dallas walker's praise we are the
ones we've been waiting for it's clear
the politicians ain't going to do it you
know the military ain't going to do it
who is it oh as miss piggy would say and
you know
it doesn't mean why
uh oh now we're really
but it also makes a difference and i i
used this last time when we talked
because it's a it's an image that i find
so compelling
from zen master tiknot han who died
recently
he said when the crowded vietnamese
refugee boats and he went to try to help
with them
and things when the crowded vietnamese
refugee boats met with storms or pirates
if everyone panicked all would be lost
but if even one person on the boat
remained calm and steady
it was enough
it showed the way for everyone to
survive
and then you say well who is that one
person
because the boats rocky the seas are up
there's anxiety there's depression
but also we are now facing a time of
tremendous moral challenge and
opportunity
you could either you know succumb in
some way and drown in the
depression or the
helplessness
or say
you are now being charged in this time
in human history
to stand up in some way and offer
your piece of moral courage
as a voice or an action your piece of
compassion your bodhisattva which means
just someone who wants to alleviate
suffering no matter what's happening
being willing to to see the suffering
from the despair and say that's not the
end of the story
because it is
we're survivors for
you know
centuries and millennia we know how to
do this
so i'd like to segue to two things jack
the first just because i keep planting
this flag
and i want to make sure i don't break
any promises to listeners you mentioned
tiknot han whose
books had a huge impact on me
specifically one
i don't think it's an anecdote i think
it's more of a metaphor but i remember
it so clearly i i can't quite pinpoint
why
this stuck with me in the way that it
did i'm going to come back to his death
which i i watched i watched his not his
death but his cremation
the entire procession on uh youtube
actually live streaming
the metaphor just so i can mention it
since i brought it up is he talks about
doing the dishes and if while you're
doing the dishes you're thinking of only
what you're going to do after the dishes
that if later you think you're going to
say enjoy a peach after you finish the
dishes that when you are eating the
peach you're not going to be enjoying
the peach you're going to be thinking of
whatever comes after the peach and
that's just stuck with me
for decades now that you know if you're
thinking of something else while you're
viewing what you're doing is drudgery
and you're looking forward to x chances
are when you then think you are going to
enjoy actually thinking of something
else if you don't train that present
state awareness so
a lot of a lot of his teachings have
stuck with me
let's talk about death for a second
and
what the specifically the wording that i
have in front of me is what happens as
you die you have
over your many decades of life now
one of the widest ranges of experiences
including non-ordinary
experiences of anyone that i've ever met
so
please expand on this in any way that
you think makes sense death and what
happens as you die i will but first i
want to pick up one take not han for a a
little moment of two parts and it will
segue into death
christina figuera is a
costa rican diplomat you may have heard
of her
i have she was the un
representative for climate
and she helped to organize the rio
climate summit that happened i don't
know a decade ago or so
and then it was her job to organize the
paris climate summit that happened i
don't know four years ago or whatever it
was
and she tells a story she said she
had gotten to a place
where there was so much contention among
the different
nations and players about whose fault it
was and who was going to do what
that she became
really despairing about climate
and about what we might do
understandably so
and maybe even a bit paralyzed
and then somebody said to her you know i
think you need to step out of this
despair place for a little bit try
something different
there's a place down in southern france
run by this vietnamese monk
named tiknot han she'd never heard of
him
called plum village why did you just go
there for a couple weeks you know get
out of dodge
so she did
and she said i went there and first of
all it slowed her down
you know she was not running like we do
we watched ignot on walk you know and he
walks
like every step you were talking about
being present like every step
is a miracle that wow i'm still alive i
can walk the earth is here here we are
what have i closed my eyes to it's
extraordinary
you know like it was the last day of his
life he's just there
and then she began to practice with him
breathe to bring some
well-being into a body that was carrying
so much tension and suffering and to let
it go to hold it in compassion to begin
to release it we told her to put a
little smile on her lips as she did it
and it wasn't like this smile of okay
denial
but it was the smile of the sages the
wise ones who've been through everything
and say we're still here we know how to
do this
and then she took the teachings of
interdependence from him
of how every breath you take is
completely breathed with
the you know raccoon in your backyard
and the earthworms and it's not a
fiction it's the reality we're
exchanging air you know i heard that
thing you probably heard it that what's
the likelihood that one breath
that the next breath you take will have
a molecule from julius caesar's dying
breath
and the likelihood is 99
so i heard that and i come from a family
of scientists even though i'm a kind of
a weird one in that i thought well could
that be true so i did the math i said
okay
you know
how many molecules well in one mole
there's avogadro's number and one liter
maybe
of that breath there's 10 to the 23rd
molecule okay how many liters of air and
i've looked it up how many kilometers
of atmosphere there is and then how many
liters in that it turned out it was 10
to the 20 seconds i said yeah 99
julius caesar's with you you are
breathing everybody you know
you're exchanging breath yeah with
gandhi and you know mother teresa and
vladimir putin and
and stalin and everybody else we're in
it together she saw it
and she said oh my god i've been doing
it wrong i've been thinking in terms of
victim and perpetrator which is how
everyone is seeing it you're bad and
you're being hurt and so forth
she went back
and she said i saw us as a family
as interconnected
and i wrangled 196 countries or whatever
it was and we got the paris climate
accord so this is a take not han story
but also a climate story
that's saying that there's another way
to see it
beside despairing empowerment
so when thing hot died
he wrote this thing he taught about it
for a long time he said i have not died
he said you just think i've died he said
but if you look at a cloud
the cloud turns into snow or rain it
falls in the streams and goes in the
rivers and go to the ocean the sun heats
the ocean and the cloud forms again he
said we are this
he said i'm not separate from you and
the clouds and the rain we are just the
same field of
awareness of consciousness of being and
so i was never born who i really am and
i can never die i'm with you
so i was sitting with my father as he
was dying again because i'm getting
philosophical there but people actually
wants something take nothing remarkable
so i'm sitting with my father now my
father was as i said i'm
i think now slightly mentally ill
paranoid
violent easily triggered
and so forth
and he was
near to dying
as i said he'd been a scientist who'd
helped invent heart lung machines and
things like that
yeah i'll stay with the story there's
another little one i might tell but
anyway
so i sat with him
and he was terrified of dying
he was in the
university of pennsylvania
medical center he'd been a student at
the university of pennsylvania
and um
he kept looking over at the monitor to
see if he died yet
and if anything you would notice and
because he designed some of these
monitors he was really like tuned to it
and his
his fear was really great i said so dad
what do you think happens when you die
he said nothing dirt
you go back to these i'm a scientist you
go back to dirt right i said well that's
if you're a scientist that's
that's a presumption i thought
scientists did experiments don't you
want to see what happens he said what do
you mean see what happens i said well
let me tell you my experience
i said
and i described how when i was in the
monastery i'm beginning to learn my
meditation and i got exhausted i did a
year in silence sitting in meditation or
walking 20 hours a day and i lay down on
the floor one day completely exhausted
thing i'll get up in 20 minutes and keep
going i'm going to get enlightened you
know how cool this young men are
and i got up
and i started to do this slow walking in
this cottage i was living and
i got to the window i looked out i saw
my teacher in a distance and
cottaged several places over meeting
with somebody i turned around and i
walked across the floor and i saw a body
on the floor
and i went whoo a little rush of fear
and then realized oh god it's me
i was having my first out-of-body
experience and i went close and i peered
at myself you know i said well this is
trippy and then
i fell into my body and okay i'm on the
floor and i stood up and then i learned
more how to do that so i told that to my
father
i said i had past life experiences i
remember being a monk in a kitchen and
you know the middle ages in the chinese
monastery and it was not fun and i know
all these
and then i looked into it and it was how
it was in those days and then i said and
then i've done past life regressions
with people all around the world
and people who believe it or don't
believe it it doesn't matter
half the people have these
amazing experiences and it doesn't
matter whether you believe it or not the
complete surprise
and i've sat with people and they've
died and they've gotten close and
they'll float out of their body and then
come back i said how's it going say well
i started to let go and there was this
whole field of light which i know from
meditation and dying invitation and i
was late there was this sense of love
and bliss and then i could i did a life
review which happens in a moment i saw
my whole life and what was you know what
that incarnation was like and i kept
telling him these stories i said so
when you die
i said you claim to be a scientist why
don't you take it as an experiment
because it's likely that you'll find
yourself floating out of your body
and you go whoa what's this and then
there'll be a sense of light and release
and often there's a sense of joy
you know and the sense of connection to
something so much bigger i went on for a
little bit
i said of course it might happen that
you're right and nothing happens
but from my experience inwardly and with
so many people
you're gonna start to die and you'll
float out of your body and there'll be a
lot of it'll be some prizes for you and
if that happens
remember i told you so
how did he respond to this
he
responded
medium
it got
and i felt good because i at least told
him what i knew
we are consciousness you're not your
body you oh you know you have a body but
it's not who you are
you're certainly not your thoughts oh my
god if you were your thoughts we'd be in
trouble right
they keep changing anyway one opinion to
another and you're not your emotions
they come like the tide or the
the weather
so who are you who you are
is the awareness itself that was born
into this body you are consciousness
so i got to tell him a little bit of
things that
you know my side of science sort of the
weird science side
and he sort of listened and i thought
well maybe this will be useful to him
so
all right i have to pick at what not
pick but pick up on
one thing you mentioned in passing
because a lot of folks are going to
harass me and it's also
piqued my curiosity when you mentioned
your first out of body experience yeah
and then i believe you mentioned later
learning how to do that type of thing
yeah how does one learn to do that type
of thing
and
why would one learn how to do that type
of thing what is the value so all right
the first thing is i wondered whether it
was real or not but then when i got back
in my body and i went over the window
and looked out there was my teacher and
there was the person visiting them who i
wouldn't have seen while i was sleeping
more often than not
people's experience of that kind and
it's actually more common than you think
happens
in an accident or in some great distress
and
literally you could talk to thousands of
people who said i was in this car
accident the medics came and there i was
floating above watching and they can
tell you things that happened that they
couldn't possibly have seen their eyes
were closed they couldn't see that way
so there are there are thousands of
detailed accounts of that so it's not
esoteric and you don't have to go to the
himalayas or
sit in silence for a year or something
it's actually part of our human nature
whether it's an accident or things like
that and the simplest thing i can say is
that as i got tremendously concentrated
and focused in meditation and could move
my attention different places i could
both move it into my body and then i
learned to move it into the space of
awareness that was not my body and
that's enough to say
but it's not that far away
and it i you know i don't know that it's
that valuable
per se i'm not like touting it but i
learned something just like i learned
things from taking psychedelics whoa
look at that everything's dissolving it
oh
you know it's not how i thought it was
and in fact and whatever all kinds of
things so
so i learned something of value
i may i may come back to that but it
sounds like the out-of-body experiences
wouldn't make the cut into the seven
habits of effective bodhisattvas is that
what you're saying
what makes the cut
is knowing who you are
that you're
that you're not limited by the identity
that you play in the world because we
have all these roles you know
you're a podcaster you're a writer
you're
the boyfriend or the father or the
grandmother
you're a business person or a healer or
so forth all that and all those roles
change i mean one person can be both
the father of somebody
and the son of their mother and the
grandson of their grandmother
they can both be uh well if you're a
policeman and you come home
there you are you're on your beat you've
got your uniform and you're gone and so
forth
and if that policewoman comes home
and tries to be the policewoman in her
family
she will have a very unhappy family life
right yes but not only put her gun down
just to put her identity down and become
a mom or a wife or a daughter to her
parent you know or or a colleague friend
so we have all these identities
they're not who you are
they're what your incarnation offers to
you
and you get to use them to grow your
heart and compassion
to understand the world i mean you can
have your own purpose but i would invite
people
to reflect on what would be a beautiful
purpose for this incarnation
rather than one where you just suffer
and when you start to see that then it
frees you
then the suffering isn't so much of a
problem i think of our friend ramnas
20 years in that wheelchair half
paralyzed from a stroke aphasia
repeated infections lots of body pain
and by the end of his life he just
became pure love
he said i love everything i just i'm so
grateful like taking that on for this
life i love it i love this wheelchair
it's carried me
you know i love those who take care of
me said i used to take care of everybody
and start do all these things and now
they have to pick me out of bed and wipe
my butt
i didn't like that he said i wanted to
be the hero is going to save everybody
and now
you know i have to be a vulnerable human
being and i love that too it's taught my
heart something even bigger
so what do we want to do with this life
basically you each have your measure
what do you do with it
let me ask you jack
just to
pick up on finding a beautiful purpose
i
speaking personally as someone who's
generally oriented towards the world and
my environment and people around me with
vigilance hyper vigilance
i think i have focused a lot on reducing
risk
eliminating pain
it's a subtractive approach does that
make sense it's getting rid of things
and we've talked about
for instance
contending with despair but i have to
why i don't have to but i imagine
that finding or seeking joy amidst it
all is perhaps quite different from
subtracting the bad things
yes
how would you speak to that or suggest
people think about that so first if you
forgive me i want to read you
a poem
and it's a full page poem so it's not
super short and it's one of the great
poems i love poetry that i've read in
decades
from jack gilbert who is one of our
master poets
yes please
it's called a brief for the defense
all right and it speaks to your question
sorrow everywhere slaughter everywhere
if babies are not starving someplace
they're starving somewhere else
with flies in their nostrils
but we enjoy our lives because that's
what the gods want as well
otherwise the mornings before lavender
summer dawn would not be made so fine
and the bengal tiger would not be
fashioned orange and black so
miraculously well
the poor women at the fountain are
laughing together between the suffering
they've known
and the awfulness in the future smiling
and laughing while somebody in the
village is very sick
if we deny our happiness
resist our satisfaction
we lessen the importance of their
deprivation
we must risk delight
we can do without pleasure seeking but
not delight not enjoyment
we must have the stubbornness to accept
our gladness in the ruthless furnace of
this world
to make injustice the only measure of
our attention
is to praise the devil
if the locomotive of the lord runs us
down
we should give thanks that the end had
magnitude
we must admit that there will be music
despite everything
quite extraordinary poem that really is
who is the author one more time do you
say jack gilbert jack gilbert yes
we must have the stubbornness to accept
our gladness in the ruthless furnace of
this world
to make injustice the only measure of
attention
is to praise the devil how did you find
this poem or how did it come into your
life oh i read poetry a lot and you know
i don't know where it came i've had it
for some years
and i've made friends with some poets
and i've even tried to write poetry
sadly i'm not very good at it i'm i'm i
i'm a you know
it's like you go to your favorite band
all right i'm young i'm going to go hear
the dead i wish i could play with them i
can't
but i i'm a
i'm a great fan
of a fan of good and we're lucky because
we have the great poets of the world we
have hafez and rumi and we have the
chinese poets we have lipo and we have
all these magnificent poets my good
friend luis rodriguez who was the poet
laureate of los angeles a couple of
years ago
and is a latino activist who's worked
with gangs and worked in prison because
he was in a gang in fact
his first major book
which wasn't poetry was called my la
vida loca my gang days in la
which he says proudly
is the most stolen book in high school
library
[Laughter]
and his platform as a poet he's running
for governor he wants to be
if he if he can come in second you know
so he can run against newsome he knows
he won't win he said but i want to stand
up for the homeless i want to stand up
for the farm workers you know what kind
of culture it is that these people all
work to feed us and they don't have
enough food stamps to feed their
children i want to stand up for
for climate and for public
transportation and alternatives he's got
all this beautiful platform
jack let me ask you if i could just
before we
move to your friend a brief for the
defense why did you read that and what
do you make of the title also well the
brief for the defense is it's in defense
of joy
and i'll go back to it with you i'm
happy to
andre jeed the great french philosopher
said
when you understand correctly
you must embrace joy as a moral
obligation
and we'll stay with that for a moment of
joy
for there's a book and now a movie that
came out the book of joy you may have
seen it
that's a dialogue between
archbishop desmond tutu
who recently died
and the dalai lama
about joy
and part of what's in that book it's
mostly in a record of their dialogue
they each acknowledge the immense
suffering that they've been through and
the people around them heard
due to the incredible suffering under
apartheid and all the conflicts and the
people who were killed and died and many
who he knew and thrown in prison
and what tore apart the nation really
and he was right in the center of it and
the dalai lama of course fleeing from
tibet having the chinese army burn the
sacred texts and the monasteries and
imprison
monks and nuns and take over the culture
and as he said they've taken so much
from me why should i let them take my
happiness
and they talk to each other and they're
both they're both very funny they both
have great senses of humor
and they say
you know
for them
like jid's moral obligation
the world is too magnificent and
mysterious and too beautiful
to live on the channel of despair
it's just not
so in the buddhist tradition we have
these practices where you cultivate joy
where you look through the eyes
to see first the secret beauty and
everybody going by and one of the parts
of that
practice of
joy and you could try it him
is when you look at somebody
try to imagine their happiest
day their happiest moment as a young
child
because even if they had a bad childhood
with some too
there were days when they were tickling
and wrestling and rolling around and
laughing i think if there's an
inviolable spirit in children i've seen
it in refugee camps
that just can't be stopped
and innocents in a
and so you look at that person and you
see not that adult with all their cares
and traumas and whatever their fear and
anger
but you realize that that child of the
spirit is in them
it actually still is
and then you start to remember your most
beautiful happy days as a child
happy moment somehow
and then you invite and invoke it may i
live with that spirit may i see it in
others
so tim i wanna
pick up with
the thread of joy coming out of that
poem and she's
sense of joy as a moral obligation
because people can often think about
meditation as
something like a grim duty all right
i've got to go to therapy and i've got
to work out and i've got a diet and i
should meditate as you know as if it's
some self-help thing and especially
since you asked you know when your
nervous system is all of ours is in
disarray right now somewhat and vigilant
and wary
meditation
is is not supposed to be a grim duty but
rather
more an act of adventure and
understanding of opening the mind and
heart
and bringing a sense of well-being
mahatma gandhi said
what uses freedom
if it doesn't also include the freedom
to make mistakes
my teacher aja we would ask him
different questions about things and a
lot of the times he would say it's
uncertain isn't it
you know tell me about enlightenment
he'd smile he'd say it's uncertain isn't
it well tell me what happens when you
die it's uncertain isn't it i mean he
had teachings
but he loved the wisdom of uncertainty
of our he said why don't you be just as
you talked about them
when you're washing the dishes
as tiknot han described to feel the
soapy water in your hands and enjoy
washing the dishes or being with another
person
i remember reading about these russian
astronauts who got in trouble
and were not sure they would even make
it back from their orbit above the earth
where they'd been for a while but
finally they did and their capsule came
down and opened and they said they
touched the earth with their feet and it
was the most glorious moment just to be
in the dusty plain of kazakhstan and
touch the
ground and the plants that people might
have called weeds
to see the eyes of people who were
walking around beating them or to be
able to go home and sit at a table with
people felt absolutely miraculous
and so there's something about
meditation
when we quiet the mind and yes we can
bring compassion and tend to all the
difficulties that we carry
but it's an invitation to get bigger
to feel the sense of mystery
as the poet says i'm moving at
tremendous speed toward a star in the
milky way
my heart's a little fast
otherwise everything is fine
and for you and those who listen
to remember that spirit of adventure
and joy that was there
as a child
the child of the spirit so if you would
tim
close your eyes for a moment let's just
meditate together and other people can
join us
and take a couple of long breaths
let yourself settle
and notice that there are different
channels consciousness has these
different dimensions and you can tune
into the channel of despair or the one
of outrage
but you can also tune into the channel
of the dalai lama and tutu and so forth
of adventure and caring and joy
as you sit quietly
let yourself
remember one of the best moments of your
childhood
even vaguely one of the best days of
joy laughing playing
enjoying tickling the child of the
spirit
and keeping your eyes closed feel it
and let me know if you can remember
something like that
i can
and what's it feel like in your body
stay with it
uh it feels light
unencumbered
feels
expansive
exploratory beautiful beautiful
so stay with this the quality of light
and unencumbered
expansive exploratory joyful
and let it fill your body
and let it fill your cells and dna
to remind you that this
child of the spirit this inviolable joy
that was born into you is still really
available
it can't be taken from you no matter
what
so just let it open and
feel it filling your
whole being
in an
easy
joyful way
and now let yourself imagine
that some being
who carries the spirit of joy and wisdom
amidst everything in human life
some amazing being
comes to join you
you know as a
as a guide as a
friend
as a
inspiration
and let yourself be surprised who wants
to come this carrier of joy and
wisdom amidst it all
and see who wants to arrive or appear
and allowing this keeping your eyes
closed notice let me know who if anyone
comes
well it's actually a friend of mine is
younger than i am
who i think does a pretty good job
with levity good good good good
and adventure
while also being really effective in the
world so both adventurous and joyful
adventurous and effective
and so this friend
a male female
male in this case
this guy this fellow comes and he's
there with you and you see his smile and
maybe he puts his arm around your
shoulder he's like your brother we're in
this together
come on let's have a good time
let's make an adventure where we make a
difference
and we do it with real joy
and let yourself feel that connection so
that
you're together in this
we need that from one another
and then as you feel this he reaches
into his pocket
and he has a gift for you
that's a clear symbol of what you need
to step out of that
small sense of self that you've talked
about that's
vigilant hyper vigilant
and
you know learn to try to protect
yourself
but you know he knows you're much bigger
than that
and he has the perfect symbol the gift
that will help you to be who you really
are
this joyful vast
adventurous spirit
and see what he gives to you
he places it in your hands if it's not
clear you can lift it up to the to the
light so you can see it
just what you need
what do you get from him
would you like my answer
yeah
so i don't know what well there maybe
there is no y but
it looks like a very
small maybe
inch
and a quarter inch and a half
diameter almost like a pendant but it's
a
silver circle with some type of
circular
bluish green stone in the center which
is round
all right so hold it in your hand
and then you can ask him what does this
symbolize and he'll tell you
you can know
your intuition your understanding will
come
but what does he tell you it symbolizes
uh
unending
connection the circularity of it yes the
illusion of separateness
[Music]
so hold it in your hand and he's
reminding you that part of the joy
and the adventure you can have is that
you're connected with it all you're
always connected
that circularity and there's a joy in
that a spirit you can't fall out of that
circle because it is you
you are life
and then he whispers in your ear a few
words of support for living with joy
what does she say
the first thing that came to mind was
take it easy
listen
you know and and you're laughing as you
say it and feel that laughter fill your
body
because he's really reminding you who
you are
that you can do this that this is
actually not just a channel but this is
underneath all the rest that we try to
do here we are we try to be grown-ups
responsible protect ourselves take care
of everything
take it easy you can do what you do as
he does
adventure and success
with this joyful spirit
and pause and just feel it
how is this
it feels good
yes feels
lighter
there's a certain
unwinding yes
sensation to it
beautiful so you're kind of
demonstrating in your own experience now
for other people who are listening
watching
you're really demonstrating what
meditation can do it can open you from
the
what's called the body of fear the small
sense of self
to of expansiveness and to a sense of
connection and well-being
and as you found a kind of adventure
and joy
now the beautiful thing is that even if
you're traveling and you happen to go to
costa rica or
you know
indonesia or wherever you go
that he's not far away
you can close your eyes
and he'll join you in spirit wherever
you are
because as in that circle he's part of
who you are
and it's always available in five
minutes
and this is one of the gifts of
of meditation and it's not like
pollyanna because there's a lot of
difficult things we have to
carry and mara keeps coming back with
progression and doubt and so forth and
you can say yes i see you mara i know
you're here and there's the buddha
seating
seated there saying yes i mara i see you
oh you're mara but that's not who i am
thank you jack
oh it's a pleasure pleasure to
to sense you in this way because i know
it's true for you
so then you wanted to ask a question
about loving-kindness
i did
i was inclined to ask
about loving-kindness meditation because
as you and i have discussed
uh i think quite a few years ago so it's
been a little while
it seems to be
sometimes an effective on-ramp for
westerners who have trouble with other
forms of meditation i don't know if if
that's a fair statement to make but i do
recall
for the first time doing loving kindness
meditation myself very short meditations
i mean really five minutes is what we're
talking about but doing it every
night before bed when i was working on
tools of titans this book of mine and
it was incredible to look at the before
and after
effect on my default state of being
after
five or six or seven days of just doing
five minutes consistently of loving
kindness meditation it was
quite shocking to be honest
and
for that reason i thought i would ask if
there's any loving kindness meditation
you might recommend for people who would
like to give it a shot
well first i'm glad you had that
experience and it is common for people
and sometimes to sit in meditation you
sit you close your eyes and even if
you're just trying to
breathe
and feel your breath and calm
the mind is racing or the emotions of
worry or anxiety or
other things
kind of take you over and it doesn't
feel
like it's at the first it's it's not
easy and it even doesn't feel like it's
working it does work but but in the
begin they can feel that way
the wisdom of what you're saying is
quite right
that to actually deliberately turn
the attention toward
loving kindness meditation or something
like it the joy practice that we just
started to do
and it doesn't take long in five minutes
just you just did five minutes and it
changed your state
the other practice that's also good
is a walking meditation especially if
you're upset sometimes it's actually not
that good to try to sit
but we don't naturally pace anyway but
this is more deliberately like typhon
walking
with a kind of deliberate care and
attention
and maybe bringing in a little loving
kindnesses
take each step for yourself or the
people that open your heartless
naturally
that you care about
so if people go onto my website
jackcornfield.com
there are a whole series of loving
kindness meditations if you click on
meditations
primarily audio there's a couple with
videos but primarily audio
and it helps to have a voice
guiding you through it
at least for the first while and then as
you did you can take it on and
find your own language and do five
minutes a day or ten minutes
and it will change your consciousness
really very quickly and then i love
doing it you know i can be on the
airplane flying somewhere
and i'm reading my book or
lost in whatever i'm doing and it feels
very isolating
and then i'll take three minutes and
i'll look up
and i'll look
down the aisle there's an old
grandmother and i wish her well may she
be safe and happy and loving kindness
around her with love and kindness and
then there's that pierced teenager over
there
may he be well and surrounded with
loving kindness and then there's that
old man over there and i just do two
three minutes of it kind of almost like
offering a blessing of
wishing them well
and then when
we land and we get off
i could almost like wave goodbye to
those folks because they're like oh yeah
i got connected with you you don't know
it but we are connected
and it changed it changes everything and
it happens we're walking down the street
it can happen in a moment
so some of the other things just to
recommend i have a book entitled the art
of forgiveness loving kindness and peace
which has
both stories in it and written on
instructions for joy practice and loving
kindness and compassion practice
along with those things on my website
and i do have this
what people are finding to be a kind of
amazing teacher training program
for people who are interested in
learning it for yourselves and
passing on these practices you mentioned
the mmtcp mindfulness meditation
certification program also you can find
on my website
and it's a two-year program there's ways
to start to learn meditation if you
haven't
and we've now done it for 5 000 people
in 70 countries and i get stories like
this woman
who's in lahore pakistan who said you
know after i've gone through this now
i'm teaching this in a girls school in
pakistan
and it's so helpful for the girls to
have the compassion and loving kindness
training and joy practices or i get a
note from a guy who says yeah i'm in
kenya and i work in a clinic and yes we
need to tend to people medically but
they also really need medicine
for the heart and i teach people and
there's so much gratitude
so for anybody interested it's a
wonderful training
and that's also
available i feel really blessed
because somehow
looking for adventure like you as we do
when we're young
i decided to go into this buddhist
monastery
and it was tough which of course we want
as young people to be initiated to try
something difficult to see what we can
learn
and as my teacher said you know where
have you learned the most when it was
easier when it was difficult so somehow
humanity has to learn this right now
we're in a place
where
the deepest sense of
what the world needs of our courage
our steadiness or being that one person
on the boat that took han talked about
to be
calm and steady in the face of these
storms
and it shows as a way for us to
reconnect
and not just to survive
but actually to be able to
instill a sense of graciousness or
well-being or love
and i think that
one of the other little practices that i
find
a wonderful reflection
in the morning
when i meditate or get quiet
is the question
what would love have me do today
what would love have me do today
and then the heart starts to answer
and you know some of it's tough that we
have to attend to this and do that
but what would love have me do today
what we're talking about is listening
and trusting
our own intuition and trusting our own
heart
to guide us
i have a little passage to read
which are instructions from
a thousand years ago or a long time ago
by this
tibetan
master meditation master teacher named
atisha
and here they are it's really what we've
been talking about and here's how we
talked about it he said advice it
teaches advice
you know
he said consider all experience
to be dreams
we take it all so seriously but there's
this vastness of the galaxies and
millions of people being born and dying
and
peace coming and war coming and joy and
sorrow and gain and loss and
consider it all to be
dreams
be grateful to everyone
thank you to everyone even the ones that
make
difficulty don't be swayed by outer
circumstances
don't brood over the faults of others
i love this one because it's so easy to
judge the others
explore the timeless nature of
consciousness
let suffering teach you compassion
at all times rely on a joyful mind
and the last is don't expect a standing
ovation
it's not a performance it's really
living your own life becoming the buddha
that you are the wise one the
wise woman or the wise man the sage
really embodying that that you just
found in yourself with your friend with
that kind of joy
that's both
able to accomplish things
but able to do it in a way that plants
seeds of well-being and adventure and
caring
thank you jack and i want to bring up
also one quote that you shared with me
long ago this is quite a few years ago i
think it was in our first conversation
on the podcast and this is i believe a
quote you can correct me from wrong
from
ryokan
ryokan
who is a quiet and unconventional soto
zen buddhist monk i'm reading for
wikipedia who lived much of his life as
a hermit also well known for poetry and
calligraphy but the quote that you
shared was
let me just make sure
i get this right
and this is ryukan referring to himself
last year a foolish monk period this
year no change period so when you're
judging yourself
harshly maybe just also remembering that
this this business of being human isn't
always easy even for people who focus on
cultivating a lot of these faculties
that's perfect last year a foolish monk
this year no change
got this
laughter in his spirit as a poet can be
thank you tim always
yes absolutely and i will include links
for everyone in the show notes to
everything we referred to so
jackcornfield.com
jackcornfield on twitter and instagram
jack underscore cornfield and for those
interested in the
lovingkindness meditations on your
meditations
section of your website which is
jackcornfield.com forward slash
meditations
i will also put some links to specific
meditations on that page in the show
notes at time blog
podcast
and thank you so much for taking the
time jack it's always such a pleasure
such a joy and so helpful to me
personally to spend time with you
well for me too i've enjoyed our
connection since the very beginning so
and it's good to see you you know
blossoming in your own unique tim way
thank you jack thank you i appreciate
that take care my friend thank you take
care jack be well bye
you